what's popping Monster Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy
spoilers show and spoilers for Monarch
Legacy of monsters episode 9 coming to
your faces because we've got to talk
about that crazy ending that causes the
Dual Narrative of Monarch Legacy of
monsters to merge in the most surprising
way so let's just jump into this new
world of possibility together my nerd
babies and hey if you like what we're
doing here on heavy spoilers maybe
considered dropping a like harder than
the US military dropped Lee Shaw into
that hole of hell really helps out the
channel man but anyways let's start off
by talking about the most wild stuff
first and I don't know about you but I
definitely consider Kate randa's meeting
with the young version of her supposedly
dead grandmother K Randa to be pretty
damn wild like how the hell did that
happen anyway well let's first talk
about those portals themselves we got
our first look at the weird space tiny
wiy effects of these Hollow Earth
portals during the episode when our
protagonists are left wandering the
Frozen wastelands of Alaska causing Shaw
May and Kate to appear to walk around in
a giant Circle to Nowhere as they froze
their emotionally traumatized butt
cheeks off Leisa then hints to the girls
that his own trip to the hollow Earth
First exposed him to these strange
effects that both of these portals as
well as the Kaiju that emerged from
those portals have on the surrounding
areas and during this episode we
definitely see some of the more drastic
sides of those effects when we see a
young Lee Shaw's Brave Journey to the
hollow Earth along with a team of fellow
researchers researchers by the name of
of Hest Burke and brand as indicated by
their helmets as soon as those explorers
are sent through the portal their
Journey causes this massive
electromagnetic gravity storm that
causes nearby metal and whatnot to bend
and random to start flying into
nearby military personnel who were
attempting to watch history as America
entered under space with the same
patriotic Pride that America would have
a few years later in 1969 when they beat
the Soviets to the moon like I really
enjoyed how they recreated the astronaut
walk with these four Hollow Earth
explorers and we actually do see a
picture of these four explorers on May's
computer earlier in the series as May is
looking through Bill randa's old files
but anyways I believe these two events
of this episode happen because of two
things with the first of them being the
electrostatic membrane of the portal
that Shaw's team went through and the
second one being the sheer force of
gravity that the hollow Earth emits on
its own just by existing by the time of
the events of Godzilla versus Kong in
2024 Apex cybernetics and mon have
recorded high levels of gravitational
distortions that happen when people
travel through these Hollow Earth
portals also referred to by doctor
Houston Brooks and the scientist at
Monarch as gravitational inversion
boundaries or jibs but unfortunately in
order to get this data the life of one
of Monarch's explorers David Lind was
lost due to not having the right
equipment to withstand the immense
gravitational shift that traveling
through these gravitational inversion
boundaries create this all being said
while the Electro static storm that bill
Randa General Pucket and the rest of the
observing audience in 1962 endured
following Shaw's disappearance into the
jib was likely due to the electrostatic
nature of these portals while the time
distorting effects of the portals
themselves are likely due to the hollow
Earth's immensely strong presence of
gravity like if you've watched any of my
previous MCU videos on my infinity stone
radiation Theory called the Marvel
trigger Theory then you'll already know
that I've talked at length about
gravity's scientific relationship with
the concept of time and how the green
Tim Stone as well as Loki's green magic
powers are tied to gravity itself like
if you haven't watched that follow-up
video on the Loki finale that I made I
highly recommend that you give it a
watch sometime by the way because it's
some really great stuff and I dive into
this concept of gravity a little bit but
anyways Marvel shed aside because this
is not a Marvel video in science the
passage of time is extremely dependent
on how strong the gravity for the people
in the area is so because of this time
flows differently on different planets
and Celestial bod IES due to those
planets and celestial bodies having
differing Mass so while the people who
live on the surface of Monarch Earth are
used to the normal passage of Earth time
due to living on Earth their entire
lives as soon as those earthlings are
brought to a different environment with
a stronger type of gravity the passage
of time flows differently for them in
that new Hollow Earth environment than
it does for anyone else back on earth
like y'all ever watch the movie
Interstellar remember when Matthew mccon
and his team went through that crazy
time dilation during their quick but
harrowing trip to that water Planet it
was due to that planet's close proximity
to a massive gravity manipulating black
hole that caused those protagonists to
be able to witness their loved ones grow
older through a series of video diaries
while they themselves barely aged at all
and again not to spend too much time on
the MCU in a non- MCU specific video but
another great example of gravity's
effect on SpaceTime in science fiction
comes in the form of sakar from Thor
Ragnarok because much like the hollow
Earth sakar car is home to a crazy
amount of wormholes that dump random
people that travel through them onto the
surface of the planet and that is very
likely due to the immense gravity that
sar's mass manipulates just by existing
because wormholes don't manifest out of
nowhere of course gravity always plays a
massive role but anyways the point of
this is I believe that it is because of
sakara's gravitational difference to
that of Earth's that Hulk was able to
meet a grownup version of his son scar a
son who did not exist a few short years
ago from Hulk's perspective due to
gravity's time dilating effect on the
planet the people living on sakar had
time passed drastically quicker than
people like Hulk who lived on earth like
it's weird as hell to think that time
isn't the same everywhere in the
universe but that's the power of gravity
man but speaking of black holes during a
previous episode of Monarch Monarch
agent Barnes actually compares the
radiation readings coming from these
Hollow Earth sites to be comparable to
the readings found from black holes in
outer space so given all of these
factors I think it's pretty safe to say
that gravity is going to be playing a
big role in Monarch just like it did in
Godzilla versus Kong but anyways this
episode also taught us exactly how
Humanity first discovered how to access
the hollow Earth reality itself with
General Pucket revealing that humans
cannot cross these gravitational
inversion boundaries without a Titan
actively traveling through that Wormhole
bridge between realities as well so in
order to get one of these Titans from
the hollow Earth to stabilize these
Wormhole tunnels Dr Suzuki's gamma
radiation simulat
was being used to bait Titans to travel
through these wormholes before disabling
the simulator halfway through their
Journey so that these traveling Titans
get discouraged from actually reaching
Earth because if those Titans no longer
smell a tasty gamma radiation food
source then they have no reason to visit
the human reality at all however now
that we know this we might now have a
better understanding of what exactly
Hoshi Randa could have been doing in the
Algerian desert since a Titan being
inside of one of these Wormhole tunnels
is necessary for human travel through
these tunnels it seems to me that
Hiroshi Randa was probably baiting a
Kaiju in order to use the tunnel himself
but that's just a guess of course but
when Hiroshi finally reunites with his
son canaro in his office at the end of
the episode he reveals that something
went dangerously wrong with his gamma
radiation simulator test in the desert
definitely implying that Godzilla
himself showing up was not part of
hiroshi's expectations for his
experiment at all however since we the
audience know that Monarch has been
noticing a strange spike in radiation
ever since Shaw and the outlaw started
blowing up Hollow Earth tunnel entrances
it would appear that Godzilla's surprise
appearance in the desert might just be
an unintended consequence of Shaw's
drastic actions because whatever he's
doing is messing up the portal structure
of the hollow Earth but anyways we of
course got to talk about the hollow
Earth itself because this place is such
an interesting realm mostly because it
seems like the very ground itself is a
conduit for massive amounts of energy
when Shaw and May first wake up in the
hollow Earth they're nearly killed by a
field of charged lightning strikes that
Shaw States happens every time one of
those Rifts close which is something he
of course saw firsthand as Monarch
Explorer Burke had one of those blasts
of lightning cut straight through her
body but even outside these random
bursts of lightning that shoot upwards
towards the rocky Hollow Earth Sky the
background of Shaw and may surroundings
in this episode glow with blue and
orangish yellow energy the same two
colors that have historically been
associated with Godzilla and Kong
respectively the logo and promo
materials for Godzilla versus Kong very
strongly associate these two Titans with
those two colors and the battle axe that
Kong uses in Godzilla versus Kong
appears to be a symbolic unification of
these two energy sources as it appears
to be a weapon empowered by both these
blue and orange Hollow Earth energies
with the sharp part of the axe of course
being made of one of Godzilla's species
blue radioactive scales and the Very
handle of the axe being the energized
bone of an unnamed species but seeing as
Godzilla versus Kong was a story about
the unification of both Godzilla and
Kong after a legendary rivalry between
their ancestors it would not surprise me
at all if this orange energy was tied to
the Kong species the scar King from the
Godzilla X Kong trailer seems to be
affiliated with this orange theme as
well but anyways the point is much like
how the Godzilla versus Kong movie first
showed us that the terrain of the hollow
Earth was permeated by this mysterious
blue glow of powerful radiation from the
very core of the hollow Earth the
Monarch show is also seeming to imply
that this blue energy source is only one
type of meaningful type of energy in
this Cinematic Universe there seems to
be a balance between blue and orange
here but anyways this episode of course
has a new type of Kaiju popping up onto
the scene in the form of this giant
warthog with tree bark like skin skin
that it undoubtedly uses to camouflage
into its forc environment to protect
itself from other predatory Kaiju but we
also get the return of some familiar
mutos that we've seen before like when
we see Shaw watching TV footage of the
Honolulu Kaiju face off between Godzilla
in the main Muto Titan from the 2014
movie a face off that would kick Lee
Shaw out of retirement but another
returning Kaiju that might be a little
tougher to see here comes in the form of
the Dragon Kaiju that Lee KO and Bill
ran into at the wreckage of the USS Lon
that particular Kaiju species seems to
make their appearance as the very same
Kaiju that appears on the hi Co
monitoring screen right before Le and is
soon to be slain team make their descent
into one of the planet's many spicy
gamma irradiated booty holes and I
honestly believe that we see the same
Dragon appear again later on right
before they're about to claim the life
of Monarch Explorer Hest and once more
as they fly through the very same portal
that ends up sending Lee Back to the
Future 20 years into the future actually
which would make Lee closer to 70 than
to 90 which is of course why everyone
says he looks good for his age because
he's not actually 90 and when Lee
arrives to the year 1982 from his
original 1962 he runs into an adult
Hiroshi Randa after holding hoshi's
future wife amiko hostage Shaw instantly
knows that he's looking at an older
Hiroshi after Hiroshi presents the very
same pocket knife that Lee gave to him
when he was a child these pocket knives
are actually called higonokami knives
and they became super popular around
1896 after metalsmiths were forced to
become creative with their livelihood
after the era of katana wielding Samurai
came to a close every higonokami knife
has the name of the maker of the knife
as well as the type of metal the knife
is made out of carved on the side these
knives were super popular to have back
in the day and many people use them to
sharpen their pencils which is something
that Hoshi Randa undoubtedly did with
his knife across the world as he left
penil shavings at all of his work sites
very much implying that Lee Shaw is
someone that Hoshi thought of often as
he lived his mysterious Exploring Life a
life that he immediately starts to
regret after canaro tells him the news
of what happened to Kate but anyways
that is it for this breakdown of this
super exciting episode 9 of Monarch
Legacy of monsters good God do I love
the Cinematic Universe so much it is so
cool to be able to see the scientific
side of all of this cool monsterverse
stuff and watching the show has
literally made me super excited for the
new Godzilla X Kong movie coming out
because I have got to know the secrets
of the hollow Earth now man like all of
this science stuff is like cracked to my
science loving brain but anyways you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
Instagram or wherever I am on the
internet but most importantly you can
follow heavy spoilers here on YouTube
and make sure you hit that notification
Bell so that you always get
notifications every time we upload a
video because that's how we do things in
2024 do not forget to be kind to one
another before I see you guys again cuz
the world sucks and everyone needs a
little kindness all right guys love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye